don't cook with so much salt shoot
that's all hypertension and high blood
pressure get that part in
okay i'm through now i'm preaching now
i'm sorry
i'm antoinette robertson i'm burgundy
baker and i'm gary anthony williams my
name is terrell i'm golden brooks and
i'm martha avery
[Music]
i'm cooking something for the barbecue
because black people pick on you when
you bring something from the store
that's like a a rule right yeah you
don't bring nothing in plastic from the
store that has some label on it that you
tried to scratch off that little code so
people can see how much it costs yeah no
oh do you know them cousin's going to
come it doesn't even invite it yeah
store-bought for sure
if it was under like 15
i'll cook not stop store-bought well i'm
cooking
110
now wait a minute i haven't ever tasted
your cooking oh you know everybody who
thinks they can cook i know i can't you
know it's like in the shower you sound
so great
i know i can't sing
i'm honest about my talents and i can
cook
let's talk about it
[Music]
i really appreciated going to college
out of state shout out clark atlanta
university you know what it is 2016. yes
sir i went to undergrad in state uc
berkeley go bears yeah and i went to
sarah lawrence out of state so i i know
i'm not answering the question but i
think both are important yeah i'm state
i'm an adventurer i need to be away
in-state is cheaper
i'm going out of state
well i was self-taught and home-schooled
which meant
i
taught myself at my house i never went
to school
my parents thought i was at school
i was just i was in the garage the whole
time uh reading the books
[Music]
life is too short to be miserable
i'd rather
deal with my passion but if you have a
lot of money you could probably work
work at the job that you hate for an
hour and spend the rest of your money
traveling you have to have some kind of
perspective here i'd rather be rich and
work at a job i hate now let me explain
because i can take that money and use it
and invest in something that i really
love to do so in essence i'm really
getting what i want
give me the money
yeah give me the money to sh money yeah
you do like schmoney i know that i saw
you at the shmatim machine
getting out some smash the other day
i mean with music a movie's not gonna
make you
like a music
oh my god
i don't have to watch movies no movies
only i don't need a movie i don't need a
movie i need tv i don't need tv i don't
need no camera
right
we don't have to take it so far no i
don't need none of it they don't play
movies at weddings
so i'm gonna need that music oh yeah we
can't dance to i i'm gonna have to go
with him
i'm going to a party family gets
christmas thanksgiving birthdays i'm
gonna go to a party for drinking my
family is boring my family's pretty uh
i don't want to call you all boring but
you just you know you're fun deficient i
would say
at home with my family because most
likely it's going to be a party anyway
because people are going to be invited
over i'm probably going to bend the
rules a little bit as long as my family
there i'm going thank you buzzfeed if
that was fun make sure you check out
block party
[Music]
that contraption is not made for black
women
[Music]
[Music]